- Our next guest started his radio career
in Los Angeles over 20 years ago,
and has since become the voice of L.A.,
and just last week, he became
a permanent part of L.A. history,
by receiving his star on
the Hollywood Walk of Fame.
Please welcome, Big Boy.
(crowd applauds)
- It is my pleasure to be here.
- We are so honored.
- Thank you, thank you.
Hello there.
- Did you ever think that you would
have a star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame?
- No.
You know, as a kid growing
up, I never thought of that.
You know, I've been to Hollywood.
Hollywood is one of those places where
you walk down the street
and you look at those stars,
but I've never walked down
the Boulevard and said,
I'm going to have one of those.
You know, as a kid growing up Drew,
I was like, I had big dreams and
I would always tell my mom,
I would say, oh mom, you know,
one day I'm going to be famous.
One day, I'm gonna sign autographs,
and my mom never deflated anything.
We were homeless and as seven kids,
my mom and I told her, I said, mom,
one day, I'm gonna buy you a house
so you won't have to be,
we won't be evicted again.
She said, baby, I know you will.
And I felt like I wanted to be the person
that took care of my mom
and took care of my family.
And when I got into radio,
I was able to buy her that house
that I told her I would purchase her
when I was a kid.
She never got, you know,
(crowd applauds)
Thank you, thank you.
- I've followed your career my whole life,
because I listened to you on the radio.
What was that first gig like?
What was it like to hit the big time?
And can you talk about
the music of that time?
Because that also is so much
a part of the DNA of who I am.
- Right.
- That time is one of the best times,
I believe, in music history.
- Yeah, yeah.
Getting into, getting into radio for me,
I started at Power 106 in 1994.
I knew some guys by the
name of The Baker Boys.
You probably remember The Baker
Boys, early in the morning.
And with The Bakers, I was just friends
and I never thought, oh let me, you know,
I can get a job here. I can get a job.
Their boss called me up one day
and asked me if I wanted to try radio
for one night, four hours, $35 an hour.
I'm thinking like, oh, okay.
I'm just doing the math, not the career.
I'm doing the math.
Like, okay, well what's that a hundred?
Okay.
And I do the math.
I go, I get the second night
he calls me the next day.
I get the second day.
Now at this time Drew
I'm over at that time,
I'm probably like 450, 500 pounds.
That's where the name Big Boy comes from.
I was over 500 pounds.
- [Drew] That's right.
- And so I thought about it and I said,
well, let me just try this radio thing.
So I went and tried radio
and that was 27 years ago.
(crowd applauds)
And with the music, I
was a fan of the music.
So in 1994, I'm going in
playing people that's from L.A.,
I'm playing Snoop Dogg,
I'm playing Dr. Dre,
I'm playing Ice Cube.
- You know, that was the time of music,
and even earlier, like I was
really into Grandmaster Flash,
I was really into Strafe, Monie Love,
Slick Rick, EPMD, Public Enemy.
- Oh, you got a hip hop card.
- Oh, I mean,
- If we moved this out the way,
she probably start pop
locking and break dancing.
- This, this is what we grew up on.
And it's, it formed me.
And I liked putting images to music,
and as a filmmaker and a producer,
and certainly we fell in love with
a director named McG who
had no credits to his name
except for music videos.
And I went to Sony pictures
and I was like, you know,
as kids that you're trusting your
hundred million dollar
Charlie's Angels movie with,
well, we'd love this guy to direct it.
His name is McG and they're like,
he has done music videos.
And I was like, I know,
and he's the only one
who gets the tone of the
movie we want to make.
And I'm so proud to say
that you are in one of
the Charlie's Angels.
- Yes I am.
- You're in Full Throttle.
We have a photo of it right here.
- [Big Boy] Hello.
- And just, it was so fun
to work with you then.
- Thank you.
- It's a pleasure to be with you now.
- Congratulations on your
star on the Walk of Fame,
the streets that you walked on.
- [Big Boy] Thank you.
- With hopes and dreams,
proving that hopes and
dreams do come true.
And we also know that
you just had a birthday
and to celebrate your birthday,
we have a little something for you.
- Uh oh.
Uh oh, uh oh.
Thank you.
- [Drew] I'm just gonna hold it up.
- Man.
Thank you so much.
- I just want to say I'm so happy for you.
- Thank you.
- And I've just been one of
your biggest fans for so long.
- I have been a big fan of yours as well.
- Oh, thank you.
- You know that.
Like for real.
- Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
I'm just, this is so fun for me.
Okay, Big Boy, congratulations
and happy birthday to you.
Be sure to check out Big Boy's new show,
After Hours With Big Boy
starting on October 7th on
a new platform, Looped In.
(theme music)